[Music]
khloe kardashian's one hot mama and
she's serving looks just own whatever it
is coco is not missing a beat stepping
out days after e.t confirmed she
welcomed a son via surrogate
check out the reality star sizzling in a
little black dress for dinner at no boot
in malibu we can't get over her sleek
look
a top knot bun matching sunnies and a
pop of blue with her handbag fitting for
her new role as a boy mom
this marks chloe's first public
appearance following the arrival of her
and tristan thompson's new edition a
baby boy whose name has yet to be
revealed a source tells e.t chloe is so
grateful to have been able to expand her
family i never thought i would have only
one child another one would just add
more love to the house our source says
chloe and tristan are excited to expand
their family the two are already parents
to four-year-old daughter true
he's a really hands-on dad and me and
tristan don't have tension we get along
really really well
and so it's just easy to co-parent with
him but as we know it wasn't exactly
smooth sailing with tristan before baby
boy arrived the former couple announced
they were expecting another child
together via surrogate seven months
after news broke that the nba star
fathered a son with fitness model
marylee nichols
everything is a lie everything is
manipulation it's deceit to tristan have
every opportunity to tell me yes was
tristan going to tell me if there wasn't
a baby involved absolutely not and that
shows a lot about his character fans saw
the paternity scandal all play out on
the family's hulu series the kardashians
and looks like we're in for another wild
ride in season two
coco telling cameras she's not giving up
on romance i do believe in love when you
love you know you're alive but ahead of
the show's september premiere we're told
the good american founder has been
living it up
back in june e.t learned coco was dating
a private equity investor and sister kim
set the two up while the fling has since
fizzled out chloe's family is fully
behind her finding her soul mate a
source told us they support chloe
getting back out there and dating again
it's a beautiful thing meanwhile tristan
has mixed feelings about chloe moving on
our source adds quote tristan was
respectful about chloe dating again as
well but knows it is also complicated
everyone wants that fairy tale everyone
wants the happily ever after i think
that's the hope
[Music]
you